the anomalous religions that the scp
foundation has catalogued and studied
over the years are many in number and
bottomless in depth with specialized
paratheological researchers limiting
themselves to just one or maybe two
faiths diving fully into a religion of
their choice and mastering its forbidden
knowledge but the foundation is careful
to make sure that those researching
these faiths don't succumb to their
beliefs as many anomalous religions are
dangerous to the organizations in
practice involving tasks such as making
blood packs with ancient gods or
modifying one's body to better suit a
divine purpose there's some seriously
nasty stuff involved in the immaterial
world almost to the point where it makes
you wonder why anyone would be suckered
into joining up with what appears to be
from the outside just another cult of
crazies but let's not generalize
religions even those that are
non-anomalous are all strange from the
outside even if one may seem natural to
you but one anomalous religion stands
out from all the rest as having more
active followers more history and more
documented culture than any other and
that is sarcasm hold on to your flesh
because today on scp explained we're
going to be answering the question what
is sarkicism and hopefully don't get
distracted and ritually sacrifice you
the viewer in the name of the grand
karcist ion along the way let's get to
it meat bags before we begin it's
important to note that sarkicism is an
incredibly dense and deep religion and
that covering every last detail of it in
a short period of time would be a
herculean nigh impossible task for even
the most well-read sarkic lore masters
so where would you even start what is
sarkicism to best understand that we're
going to bring you back all the way to
the beginning of human history to the
ancient world of the eurasian continent
where sprawling empires ruled in war
between them was an all-too-common
occurrence in what is now central
siberia the david empire ruled with an
iron fist the deva were a warrior
culture with militarism conquest
gruesome human sacrifice and
thaumaturgic magic rituals being
universally consistent in their culture
according to the few historical accounts
available that make mention of the
empire the devites practiced anomalous
magic arcane rituals and sacrifices that
bolstered their power longevity and
standing within their society the empire
was ruled by a theocratic aristocracy
called the deva those who were
especially attuned to the anomalous
world who practiced cannibalism and
thaumaturgy and whose bodies were so
warped and modified by decades of magic
alteration that foundation historians
would come to the conclusion that the
deva were so divergent from modern
humans that they could be considered a
separate species altogether but how the
deva relate to sarkicism remains the
question and the answer is found in the
empire's slave owning culture the
davites owned many many slaves people
they had brought or taken from their
lands as a sign of pure devite power in
the form of ownership over another human
being david city-states had massive
sprawling slave populations and among
those was a young boy by the name of ion
ion's appearance would be depicted over
the years by sarkic art and culture as
inconclusive and varied whether it was
their gender or even the question of
whether or not ion resembled a human the
cult of personality that would crop up
around ion would be a testament to
sarkicism's eventual widespread culture
but it was here in ancient western
siberia where those seeds of sarkicism
originated according to the most
prominent sarkic texts ion was a slave
like many others in the david empire
born into slavery by a device mother and
a concubine father the circumstances of
ion's birth indicate that he was
destined to be a slave from the onset
but there was something remarkable about
them ion in the eyes of his masters was
different from other slaves he was
intelligent and so much so that the
decision was made for ion to serve under
a devite priestess where he could hone
his skills to serve the empire in ways
unlike the other slaves who toiled away
constructing massive public works or
died in foreign lands on the field of
battle ion did not understand what
differentiated him from others and why
he deserved such special treatment but
it was the realization that the only
thing separating him from his masters
was the possession of power that would
serve as the basis for sarkicism's
founding doctrines ion watched in horror
as those they knew succumbed to the
backbreaking work that the empire forced
upon its slaves and how prevalent death
and destruction were among its people
inside ion grew a great rage for the
devites who flaunted their power over
others in the form of slavery he wished
to transcend the physical limitations
that kept him and his fellow slaves in
bondage and service to the devites ion
knew that their masters practiced
thaumaturgy a form of magic that granted
great power to its users and in a brutal
world where power is what defines who is
master and who is slave the prospects of
achieving it became more important to
ion than anything else if he could
harness such power for himself ion could
break free from the chains of slavery
that kept him subservient to those
device masters he would achieve
apotheosis the belief that an individual
could ascend to godhood through raw
power and unbridled will over time ion's
hatred of the so-called living gods of
the deva grew so strong that he actively
began plotting their downfall around
1800 bce ion's influence among the
lowest ranks of the empire was
inescapable he was charismatic he was a
slave he was powerful and he spoke of
violence of seizing davite magic for
himself and using it to elevate himself
into power ion's tenets and beliefs
appealed to the slave population who
also grew hungry for freedom ion's creed
spread like wildfire and would form the
basis for all sarkic belief in the
centuries that came first there was
apotheosis which ion was striving to
achieve and the path to doing so was the
will to power the next belief covered
that concept in depth ion believed that
the will to power was the primary
driving force of man as an individual
seeks to master all things within its
domain they exert that power onto others
and others have the ability to exert it
back in opposition desire is the measure
of power and those with a stronger will
always triumph over the weak the next
belief was the act of theophagia a
hypothetical tenant that ion was toying
with after observing the daevite
religion for years theophagia referred
to the act of sacrificial consumption of
a god and upon eating them achieving
thaumaturgical reality bending and
all-powerful abilities there were many
gods in the universe and this ion knew
but none of them were fit for him to
worship instead he would crave their
power as a metaphorical example of
theophagy ion wanted nothing more than
to consume the davite empire whole
taking its power for his own next there
was the idea of sacrifice whether it was
for the sacrifice of the self for the
benefit of many or the sacrifice of many
for the benefit of the individual ion
believed much like his masters that
ritual sacrifice was a powerful tool
that could be used as a means to achieve
and end those who commanded the
sacrifice were showing their power
bringing them that much closer to
apotheosis those who were sacrificed
were experiencing strife which would
only make them stronger than before
muscles suffer damage but eventually
heal the mind develops toleration
against hardship such as slavery this
cycle of destruction and regeneration
and strife was according to ion one of
the greatest tudors in the natural world
ion's final core belief would be the
most prominent outward-facing indicator
of sarkicism and that was the idea of
shepherding the flesh ion believed that
all living things descended from a
single progenitor an all-powerful god
known as yaldaba who the sarkists would
later regard as the principal power in
the universe yaderboth's relationship
with sarkicism is tenuous at best with
modern sarkic cults either admiring or
fearing the enemy one thing is certain
though yadabath remains present in all
sarkic culture even if the religion
doesn't exactly worship the god itself
yadabath was a destroyer who fed upon
gods worlds and stars who incidentally
created the entire universe and life
itself as a result of its power-hungry
actions the creation stories talk of
yaodaboth as a blind entity driven
solely by instinct fueled by the forces
of primordial chaos as life was created
as a result of yadubat's existence it
was ultimately unguided by intelligence
and its spread throughout the universe
was similar to that of a germ than
anything grand or defined ion upon
learning of these myths came to the
conclusion that the multiverse itself
was only an altar that held life's
existence which was brought into reality
for the ultimate sacrifice at the hands
of yadava the entity would one day
reclaim all of existence for itself
harvesting what it created and consuming
it whole as this was yaldabath's nature
and purpose as the ultimate being of the
cosmos ion saw this shared ancestry
among life as the key to genetic
modification as all life was derived
from yadubat it held a similar genetic
code and it would become the sarkic
right to guide and cultivate organic
matter stealing the genes of other life
forms or creating entirely new ones
through this perversion of life ion felt
he could ascend from something ordinary
to a living god fueled by the unending
cycle of sacrifice and creation with his
radical power-hungry beliefs rapidly
spreading throughout the david empire
mostly among its slaves the leading deva
became fearful of ion attempts to
assassinate him or usurp ion's influence
were met with failure and only fueled
the mission of his followers furthering
the belief that if they were to achieve
godhood they had to overthrow the
devites who were the most present
all-powerful beings in their lives this
all came to a head when ion launched his
final act against the david empire after
years of sowing the seeds of disharmony
and hate among the slave population ion
rallied his followers and swept them up
into a full-scale rebellion in a short
time ion overthrew the province he grew
up in fueled by the rage of his
followers who mercilessly raised the
city and slaughtered the davites like
animals those who were present could see
the inscription ion brought to his
followers how he commanded them as if he
were a living god how he used the
reality-bending magic of the deva and
turned it against them with his
followers utilizing anomalous warfare in
a horrific gruesome way flesh was turned
into a weapon living beings were
contorted and transformed into
monstrosities and abominations that
fueled the sarkic war machine deva
thamaturgy simply could not compete
against the permeating powerful and
unrestricted abilities of ion's
followers before long the city fell
before the being who had in that moment
of bloodlust and fury achieved
apotheosis the being who was now known
as the grand karcist ion the grand
karcist and his followers rampaged
through the ancient world felling cities
and entire empires to serve as stepping
stones in their path to godhood their
weapons and armor were unlike anything
else at the time and their utilization
of powerful flesh-bending magic made
them unstoppable on the field of battle
the city of adityam was established as
the sarkic holy city where ion ruled as
the sorcerer king and as a living deity
texts from this period suggest that ion
had somehow usurped control of yadubat
the devourer itself wearing the flesh of
the old god as a sort of armor and
crafting a kingdom from its body while
the depiction is most likely only a
metaphor for how much ion resembled
yadeboth in philosophy and pure power
the image of a living god devouring and
succeeding the old one is a striking
visual that surely empowered many
sarcasts at the time another story from
sarkic mythology during this period is
the six ordeals of ion a parable that
told of six challenges that were issued
to ion by the archons the servants of
yadubat who challenged the newly crowned
king of edith by enduring their trials
ion mastered the rituals practices and
beliefs ubiquitous to sarkicism and
broke free from the bondage of mortal
limitations but the authenticity of this
myth is debated and the nature of the
ordeals and ions further relationship
with yaldebath remains unknown but why
did the grand karcist ion with his
flowing red robes and wielding his
all-powerful staff who twisted flesh and
drew blood when he so much as drew
breath fall into such obscurity that his
religion remains a mysterious and
obscure footnote in the foundation's
archives if the sarcists were as
powerful as these early texts state
where are they today why did the
horrific city of aritam built of living
organic material that stood monument to
ion's indomitable will fall in
sarkicism's golden age from 1600 and
1200 bce the religion's permeation was
inescapable like the diseases they
wielded in their wars sarkicism spread
like a contagion around the world
everywhere they went they assimilated
tribes and villages into their ranks
fighting under the banner of aritam and
the sarkic faith this expanded empire
would be referred to as kalmaktama or
the deathless many tried to defeat these
brutal invaders including the king of
the hittite empire himself but all fell
before them as the kalmaktama empire
attempted to establish a foothold in the
mediterranean invading and colonizing
the islands of cyprus crete and gyros
for the first time in sarkic history the
tides of war began to turn against the
religion a coalition of kingdoms were
formed in response to the sarkic threat
created by the egyptians greeks minoans
canaanites assyrians and most
importantly the mechanites who were the
followers of the church of the broken
god the cult of meccan the broken god
had urged these kingdoms to unite
against the sarkic threat and now united
outfitted their allies with superior
mechanized technology that anomalously
enhanced the empire's war capabilities
putting them on par with the sarkic
death sorcerers and so a great war was
waged between the kalmaktama empire and
the coalition of kingdoms the details of
such are largely lost to time but the
war itself was fought with the full
power of the sarcists and the mechanites
clashing with one another and its
consequences left an imprint on the
earth itself a death toll that estimates
place at 20 to 30 million mass graves
anomalous weapons and even the
deployment of giant mechanical beings
created by the mechanites known as
colossi that rampaged through sarkic
settlements and cities though the battle
was costly on both sides the kalmaktama
empire fell to the coalition and the
once impenetrable city of edith was
destroyed forever sarkicism would fall
into obscurity and the empire would be
forgotten possibly because it was much
easier than remembering the horrors ions
subjected the world to the grand karcist
himself disappeared his whereabouts
unknown shortly after the fall of
eddietum some said he had ascended into
godhood leaving the world behind others
said he was slain in battle nothing more
than a man who believed he would never
die the sarkic religion was effectively
extinguished from the world never to be
seen again or so that's what the
coalition was led to believe though the
empire and attitum fell and ion
disappeared an idea as tantalizing and
powerful as sarkicism is difficult to
snuff out entirely in reality sarkicism
would continue in secret in both its
homeland in the urals and among the
offshoot tribes that had fought under
aditum's banner these sects of sarkicism
would practice their beliefs in their
war-ravaged homeland which suffered a
great collapse resulting in the fall of
kingdoms a crisis of refugees and a
decline of art literature science and
technology lingering disease and famine
from psychic biological weapons spread
even to the kingdoms of the coalition
resulting in an event historians refer
to as the late bronze age collapse the
empire that was once deathless had now
fallen but its followers remained
practicing their power craving rituals
in secret and without centralization
this led to a sarkic despora where
various sects and sarkic cults each with
culturally distinct beliefs would crop
up throughout the eurasian continent
while the foundation is unsure of the
specifics of these cults activities and
beliefs elements of sarkicism would soon
begin to permeate the upper echelon of
society infiltrating carpathian cults or
sought out by nobles themselves who
ignored the rumors of devil worship and
witchcraft to seek out sarkic power for
their courts the tempting power that
sarkicism granted made it a popular
choice to be practiced in secret by
upper ranking royals and even entire
noble families from their position of
power where they had access to knowledge
influence and a fresh supply of
sacrifices sarkicism endured over time
this would result in the formation of
sarkic great houses where families
practice their own interpretation of
sarkicism the religion that was now
mutated into hundreds upon hundreds of
variations and subcultures these great
houses would focus on individualism and
applying their powers to fulfill their
self-serving needs sarkicism now
decentralized completely would spread
throughout europe via marriage as a high
society of cults and magicians whose
true motives for ruling their kingdoms
and provinces were kept hidden behind
their meaty flesh curtain of absolute
secrecy today the sarkic cults persist
and their anomalies are frequently
uncovered by the foundation
understanding them and their religion
however is another ordeal entirely and
the majority of sarkic history culture
and practices are unknown to the
organization but they're still out there
in the highest ranks of urban society in
the most remote villages of the world
there will always be those who crave to
wield flesh the followers of ion who
hope to achieve apotheosis however they
may believe they can do so though the
details remain unclear there is one
thing the foundation has realized over
its years of studying the religion
sarkicism has and always will remain now
go check out
scp-3989 the bone orchard and scp-610
the flesh that hates for more of those
squishy sarcasts